Hello, this is Dr. Palmer.
I am recording a lecture
on Rheumatologic
Diseases. This is a three
-part series, and today
we're going to start with
a presentation on Diseases
Affecting the Joints.
If you can reach me by
email, my email is wpalmer at
nyot.edu if you have any
questions about the lecture.
So at the conclusion of
this, our objectives are we
need to be able to describe
the presentation and diagnostic
tests used to diagnose
the following conditions.
Today rheumatoid
arthritis, compare that
to osteoarthritis,
gout, and pseudogout.
Also we're going to
describe seronegative
spondyloarthritis presentations
and that includes ankylosing
spondylitis, psoriatic
arthritis, and reactive
arthritis and we should be
able to differentiate between
the conditions affecting
primarily the joints.
So that's what we're
going to do today.
Remember a general overview
of autoimmune disease.
So we must have a genetic
predisposition, and
this is an association
with HLA genes and an
environmental trigger,
and we must see tissue
injury. Now the way this
all happens may vary
from condition to
condition as far as what
areas are affected and
what the mechanism is.
The environmental triggers
may differ as well.
Those can be infections
to anything from
sunlight to smoking.
Some of them are unknown.
So this picture is
a picture of genetic
susceptibility showing
that you have susceptible
genes and then you
have a failure of self
-tolerance so remember
your immune lectures,
we get the self
-reactive lymphocytes and
those attack tissues,
we get inflammation
and again,
environmental triggers
are helping spur that along.
And then we get
the tissue injury
which is the
autoimmune disease.
And we'll talk more about
what if not all these are
present, what that means.
So as we're going
through this lecture, we
need to be thinking
about who, what, when,
where, why, and how.
What is it? How does it
present? How do you
diagnose it? Who gets
it? Is it occurring in
certain demographics?
When does it occur?
Is there certain
ages that these are
more predominant in?
Does it affect the body? Is
it affecting certain joints
over other joints? How do
we diagnose it? And that
includes the clinical
presentation, history, physical,
are there any labs that we
need to do? And why does
it matter? How does it
affect the quality of life?
So imagine a 45-year-old
woman presents to her
primary care doctor with
hand pain and stiffness.
These are affecting both
hands and occurring for
the past six months. So
when we look at these
presentations, this
presentation as you learn
rheumatologic diseases, this
should tell you something.
The age, the complaint,
the length of the
complaint, all those
things are important.
So let's talk about rheumatoid
arthritis. This is the
first one we're going to
get into. And what it is, is
it's chronic. It principally
attacks the joints. There
is certain terminology
that's used here, and that's
non-supportive, proliferative,
inflammatory synovitis.
Note the synovitis,
okay, as far as
the key word of
where it's attacking.
It is associated with an
autoimmune response, the
CD4 helper T cells reacting
against a joint antigen.
There are associations, we
talked about HLA, so HLA-DR4.
Smoking and infections can be
the environmental triggers.
So that presentation is
joint pain and stiffness.
You can see on
exams swelling and
redness. It can
affect multiple joints
including the hands
and the fingers.
Key is to note they
are symmetrical.
And when you look at
morning stiffness,
people can complain
about morning stiffness.
But the key here is
that it's lasting 30 to
60 minutes. It can also
be described as also
having occurring after
prolonged activity.
But the takeaway here is
that it's lasting for a
while. It's not that I get
up first in the morning and
I'm a little stiff, but
as soon as I'm going in a
few minutes, I'm better.
No, it lasts for a while.
And then the symptoms also
have to last longer than
six consecutive months
for you to consider this.
Now, with rheumatoid arthritis
and a lot of autoimmune
conditions you're going to
see over the course of the
three lectures, there may
be other symptoms that may
present. in this case it
could be malaise and fatigue.
It is more common in
women, female patients.
It peaks 30 to 40s. It is
associated with smoking
use and it affects about
1% of the population.
We're going to see this
picture several times
and it's key to note
that certain Certain
joints are affected by
different conditions.
For example, here, these
joints are affected by
rheumatoid arthritis, and as
well as these joints across
the hands, and as well as
the wrist, but when you look
at other conditions as
well, it helps you form your
differential, and we're
going to talk about all of
these. Not all of them today,
we won't talk about lupus
today, but again, we'll
talk about these conditions.
We talked a little bit about
the malaise and fatigue,
but you can also have fever.
You can also have weight
loss. There is what's called
Felty syndrome, and that's
when you have rheumatoid
arthritis, and then you get
neutropenia and spleenomegaly.
You can also find
rheumatoid nodules, and I'll
show you a picture of that.
Here's an example
of the effect of the
the joint where now
we have some ulnar
deviation and here
we can see those
rheumatoid nodules
that you can find and
that's on the extensor
surface of the forearm.
Other findings that you can
see classically is what's
called the swan neck
deformity and you can see how
this is making a curve in
the finger and then you can
see the boutonniere deformities
as well on this side.
When you look at x-rays,
we want to see signs
of harm. So besides
seeing these kind of exam
findings on an x-ray
of the joint in someone
with rheumatoid arthritis,
you'll see erosions,
you'll see osteopenia
of the areas
and narrowing of
the joint, and like
I said, the ulnar
deviation as well.
So how do we make
the diagnosis?
Well, we need to show
the harm. So that's
where you find On
radiographic findings, you
can see those specific
findings will help you
rule this in versus
rule other conditions.
There's also labs,
rheumatoid factor, anti-CCP,
okay,
ANA, sed rate, CRP, but
look down here about what's
sensitive but not specific.
Rheumatoid factor,
you know, if you have the
anti-citrullinated peptide,
if it's positive, you
pretty much have rheumatoid
arthritis, but not
everyone may test positive.
ANAs can be positive,
but it doesn't mean
that it's rheumatoid
arthritis. And as we're
going to learn about
ANAs, we're going to see
that they're positive
with a lot of things.
Sed rates in CRPs
can help assess
severity or like
active inflammation,
but again, are not
used for diagnosis.
So a little bit
about sensitivity of
tests. We're going
to look at this sheet
here and we're going
to see this again.
I'm going to show this
several times throughout
the course of these lectures
where you're going to
see these different
conditions because today we're
going to talk about
rheumatoid arthritis and
you can see the percent
of it being positive for
these other conditions and
we've highlighted these
areas but when you compare
it to lupus which we'll
learn about in the next
lecture and some of these
others that we learn in
the next two lectures,
this table will make
more and more sense
as far as how you are
using the serology
to help determine
what the condition is.
Here are some pictures
of the radiographic
findings as far as the
osteopenia, the joint space
narrowing, the ulnar
deviation, you can see
the squall neck deformity
over here as well,
the erosion.
Still a brief treatment
on that. You're going to
treat symptoms, inflammation,
and progression.
Your main goal is to use DMARDS
and
medicines include
anything from steroids,
corticosteroids,
immunosuppressants, methotrexate,
biologics, TNF,
alpha inhibitors.
Our goals of
treatment are going
to be minimize the symptoms,
prevent progression
into joint deformity,
improve, maintain quality
of life And we want to
help control the extra
-articular manifestations,
you know, considering by
disease and treatment.
Because while my joints
hurt, I don't feel well,
the rheumatoid arthritis,
the severity of it, the
treatment of it,
ultimately still leads to
cardiovascular disease and
cardiovascular death as
the concern for the
patient's life expectancy. So
we're going to switch
gears here a little bit.
Now let's talk about a 55
-year-old man presenting
to the doctor with
hip pain. This has
been affecting his left
hip for the past 10 years,
but now is limiting
his daily activities.
So this is osteoarthritis,
a degenerative disease of
the articular cartilage.
It is a secondary
inflammation. It is, think of
wear and tear. You may have
a predisposed deformity
as well that kind of leads
you into this condition.
It could have been an injury
as well, also as a cause.
It is still more common
in female women patients.
There's no conclusive evidence
of genetic relationship.
It is typically in the
late 40s when it starts,
being overweight,
having competitive
contact, sports, occupation,
wear and tear. Those are the
risk factors to identify.
Conset very well is insidious.
Pain typically is
short in duration,
but it can be later prolonged.
It increases with
activity or stress.
It's usually more
often related to the
overuse or prior
injury location. It
can also interfere
with quality of life.
Think about questions
regarding previous injury
to the joint, what
they historically have
done for work or exercise
or sports as a kid.
Pain increases with
activity or stress. Now
while there may be
complaints of stiffness,
the morning stiffness
is not like it is with
RA in the description of
longevity or the degree.
and this is historically
more worse as the
day goes on. So more
worse after the activity.
On exam findings
you may see things
like Heberton nodes
on the DIP joints.
The PIP joints may
have Bouchard nodes.
X-rays you'll see some
joint space narrowing.
Historically you'll
see that more medially
here you look at the
space right here is larger
on each side laterally
but when you get in
here and see that that
space is not as big
so our debt diagnosis of
osteoarthritis are we're
not having other extra
articular manifestations our
x-rays can show findings
your your sed rate is
going to be negative fluid
aspiration of a joint is
also going to be negative
we should not have positive
auto autoimmunity labs
that would be connected
to this and again typically
the presentation of these
are going to be more of an
isolated joint treatment
on those are going to
be strongly recommended
for exercise, physical therapy,
weight loss, supporting
like a cane if we need
it, knee brace maybe,
like an orthotic.
It just depends
on the case and the location.
There's a lot of
other options that
people can do as far
as non-pharmacology.
Pharmacology-wise
we're typically with
NSAIDs, either oral
or topical. Sometimes
steroids are also
injected into the joint.
On to the next case.
We have a 65 year
old man presenting to
the urgent care with
severe pain in his
right first toe that
started last night.
And so in this exam
we have a picture here
showing a red swollen
joint of his big toe.
So this is gout. It has
transient attacks, monosodium
uric crystals depositing
within and around the joint.
The primary cause
of this is enzyme
defects. It can
also be caused by
secondary causes such
as renal disease,
a genetic congenital
cause, or even leukemia.
Excessive uric
acid, the majority
of that is due to
reduced excretion.
You can have the increased
rate of synthesis,
since we're going to talk
about diet as far as a
treatment option, but
again it's because we're
not excreting as much to
the kidneys as we should,
and thus why renal
disease can cause gallop.
So it is more common in male
patients than female patients.
There's a possible
genetic role in purine
metabolism, but again
that's not for everyone.
It can occur at any
ages from 40 on.
It is more associated
with a diet in
the higher
socioeconomic background
population, but also
Pacific Islanders. A
little bit more
about what gout is.
This is just kind of a flow
chart on purine synthesis
and how it gets to uric
acid. And then I talked about
renal excretion as being
the primary problem here,
that we get decreased renal
excretion. So, some of the
things that you can
associate with that decreased
renal excretion, you can see
alcohol, obesity, as well
as fructose, and also that.
Now, some of the things
that we can do to improve
renal excretion of uric acid,
vitamin C, dairy products,
coffee, and weight loss.
Some of the medicines
that you'll get
from another
lecture, you can see
where some of those
will work up here.
As uric acid goes up, the
incidence of gout also goes
up, but just having an
elevated uric acid does not
mean that you're going to
have gout. Now, historically,
a person who has an
elevated uric acid will have
that before they get diagnosed
with gout. So, a gout
attack, you'll have a uric
acid elevation before then.
So the classic presentation
again would be a
male patient, obese,
possibly consumption in
alcohol, probably in a
diet high in meat and
seafoods, other medicines
like thiazides that
are used for blood pressure
can also be related
to it, or you could
find a renal impairment.
The presentation of the
joint itself is pain,
erythematous,
swollen, warm, and
it's typically just one joint.
You can see other findings
of the precipitation of
uric crystals, and you can
see what's called galptofi.
So how do we make
that diagnosis?
We want clinical suspicion.
You can aspirate the joint,
and you will find negative
birefringent crystals. and
I put kind of the definition
for that down here is that
the crystals under the
axis of the polarizer are
parallel and they'll appear
yellow under the compensated
polarized light and when
parallel when they're parallel
and then blue when they're
perpendicular and that's
the negative birefringence.
Also on diagnosis you'll
see serum uric acid increase
but again like I said
20% of people with high
uric acid will develop
gout. So it doesn't mean
that elevated uric acid
means that they have gout.
So the treatment of this,
and again you're going to
get this more again, we
have an anti-inflammatory
pod of treatment, we
have a uric-lowering
drug pod of treatment,
and we also have
lifestyle. We talked
about stopping alcohol,
weight loss, decreased
purine-rich foods,
And you'll hear about
other things that
people try to do, like
I said, like coffee
to help decrease the
incidence of gout.
So we're going to switch
to another one. A 65-year
-old woman presents to the
urgent care with severe
pain in her right knee
that started last night.
And so what we're going to
talk about is pseudogout.
And so it's sporadic.
It can be hereditary. It
can be secondary. It is
more common in women. Like
I said, there could
potentially be a genetic
relationship to the
pyrophosphate production, and it,
again, is most of them
are after the age of 50.
Pseudogout is now
called calcium
pyrophosphate
deposition disease.
The crystals form
in the hyaline
cartilage and the
fibrocartilage.
So, an example here, when
we think about, well,
where does gout versus
pseudogout happen? So, pseudogout
is more common in like
the knee than gout is.
You'll see that maybe
misdiagnosed where
someone will have
a red swollen knee
and they'll be told
that they have gout.
But again, from a stage
where you're at, you
know, you've got a red
swollen knee and it
wasn't an injury, you
need to think pseudogout.
If it's in the toe,
think more gout.
I mentioned an injury
being a prior injury.
So, if they've
currently injured it,
then that's not what
I'm saying. I'm saying,
but typically, pseudogout
is going to occur
in a joint that was
previously injured. And
it's going to be warm
and painful with fever.
Aspiration helps you
identify if there's
infection in the joint. So,
under sterile technique,
you would aspirate
the joint fluid to see
if there is signs of
infection in it. But when
you aspirate a joint
with pseudogout, you're
going to get positive
birefringent crystals.
So the treatment
of this is, again,
rest.
Anti-inflammatories
can help in SADS.
Steroid injections.
It does also respond to
colchicine prophylaxis.
And sometimes, on rare
cases, if there is
joint destruction,
deformity, then surgery.
On to the next topic is
seronegative spondyloarthritis.
These are associated
with the HLA-B27.
You will not see
rheumatoid factor.
It is probably thought
to have a T-cell
response. It affects
ligamentous attachments
instead of synovium.
So remember the keyword
that I mentioned in
rheumatoid arthritis?
It classically involves the
SI and vertebral joints.
You get bony proliferation,
which leads to ankylosis,
and these include the following
conditions. Ankylosing
spondylitis, psoriatic
arthritis, reactive arthritis.
Now, there is also
an association with
inflammatory bowel
disease. Remember,
association means that
it could happen together,
but it doesn't have
to happen together.
So, in ankylosing
spondylitis, second, third
decade, typically
more in male patients,
90% have the HLA-B27
positive, so you can
find lower back pain
and spinal immobility.
It can affect other
joints as well.
Psoriatic arthritis is male
and female about the same.
You have the history
of psoriasis,
and the ages are
kind of 30 to 55.
You may also have
HLA-B27 positive. And
so we've got some
words here, dactylitis,
arthritis, spondylitis,
and emphysitis.
It can be asymmetric,
multiple, or one joint,
and classic on the x-ray
pencil and cup deformity.
And so you can see
the solar X brick that
we attach to this and
see a picture of that.
reactive arthritis also
associated with HLAV27 we
talked about environmental
triggers it is associated
with the following infections
chlamydia, shigella,
salmonella I'm sorry for
the typo there narsenia,
campylobacteria, and claustroides
and this classic presentation
is arthritis, urethritis,
conjunctivitis and so
50% have recurrent joint
pains. That presentation
historically can't see, can't
pee, can't climb a tree.
So we used a bunch of
words and I'm going to
ask you to look these
up and write them down,
write some definitions
down. We need to know what
HLA is, we need to know
what birefringent is,
and ANA.
The next lecture, we're
going to talk more
about ANAs. Rheumatoid
factor, anti-CCP,
ESR, stendobitis, bactylitis,
spondylitis, enthesitis,
and ankylosis.
Okay, so some of these
words we're going
to see again, so we
need to make sure
that we are clear
on what they mean.
So I have some
references and we
will move on to
the next lecture.